viewers first met zachary torres
when they made history as the first
male-born contestant
on abby's ultimate dance competition and
then they went on to compete on dance
moms
yeah but now after being quiet on social
media the past few months
zachary had a big announcement and
zack's already blown away by the support
hi everyone it's me zachary torres and
you may know me from
dance moms and i realize i haven't
posted on tick tock
anything of like myself like december
and life update
i'm transitioning that means i'm
transgender if you didn't know
my pronouns are they she which means
that they or she
are totally fine and i'm just hopping on
here to tell you that i'm gonna be
posting more on tick tock
and i'm excited about it and i don't
know why i'm doing all these awkward
moves because i'm
rusty hey everyone great life update
thank you so much e online people.com
yahoo entertainment tonight et canada
thank you so much so much love
i can't even express i'm so overwhelmed
right now
love you all yeah i was also going to
mention what he wrote on uh
instagram so he said don't really have a
ton of words to express how i am feeling
right now other than grateful
grateful to everyone who has supported
me and continued to help me be my full
self grateful for the outpour of love
and support
grateful to all the advocates who made
this possible as
as i sit here with my mounts mouth still
open is important to recognize the
amount
of lgbtqia plus individuals
who do not receive this loving response
there is still work to be done and i
cannot wait to be part of it much love
and happily early pride month i know
zachary is just
full of energy and very confident in
that first video but i mean that's a
huge thing to do
to do a video like that on social media
massive massive and all kudos to her for
um
for coming out and doing that and and
just and just celebrating
and being celebrated i think that's a
lovely thing and about all the poses
like the weird poses being rusty that's
i feel like that's just a tick-tock
thing like i feel like when you're in
toothlock you feel like you
you kind of have to do that like pose
otherwise yeah like otherwise are you
really
making a tick tock i don't know yeah uh
cesco says that it's awesome we have to
support love
and nelson says that's the way to do it
just naturally no big deal uh
life is better when people are free to
be who they are and else is be out and
proud
um my boss is something i don't know
what he said in this year
um but yeah i think it's awesome like i
mean especially at the beginning of
pride month to
like do like this i think it's just
awesome as for her to put out there and
yeah like i said i mean that's a huge
thing to do like i mean she must be
really nervous
to put that out there so the fact that
she did it so
confidently and yeah i love the support
that she's getting i know there's gonna
be a ton of people
that don't give her that support and
once again people you know
we haven't had the comment yet but we'll
have people like oh why does this matter
of course it matters i mean transgender
is still matters i mean people are still
killed on the daily because they're
transgender because so yeah
having people come out as transgender is
hugely hugely important
yes and focus on the positive like let's
focus on on
the celebrating this um and it being a
great way to kick off
pride month i love it